- This video is sponsored
by Intel and ASUS
who sent me the ASUS VivoBook S14 (S435),
powered by the Intel Evo platform.
So we're going to talk more
about this in a minute.
The video for today's topic is once again
going to be Excel and
specifically shortcuts in Excel.
This is a highly requested topic.
After I did my last video
on Excel formatting,
plenty of people requested
this in the video comments.
So trust, it is going to be insightful,
and I'll really show you
what shortcuts I used
during my time in consulting,
how I was productive
working in Excel.
So we are going to dig into the
details of this in a moment,
but now I do wanna take some
time to properly introduce
you to the sponsors of today's video.
The Intel Evo platform brings
the perfect combination
of performance,
responsiveness, connectivity,
battery life, and stunning visuals
to a new class of sleek, stylish laptops.
The great performance
is powered by the 11th
Generation Intel Core processor,
and Intel Iris Xe graphics.
The laptop is designed
on the Intel Evo platform
and helps you to create,
connect and achieve more.
It was co-engineered with Intel
to provide the ultimate
experience anywhere.
So I trust, you could say that the PC
with the Intel Evo badges
verified wonderful.
The ASUS VivoBook S14 (S435)
has the new Intel Evo badge,
which means it's been verified
for premium portability.
Finding a new class of laptop
is finally as simple as looking
for the Intel Evo brand.
What I personally like most is the thin
and light stylish design,
the innovative number pad
and the yellow enter key design.
I usually always carry a
laptop with me in my bed.
Therefore, portability
is very important to me
and the ASUS VivoBook S14 (S435)
designed on the Intel Evo platform
is doing an excellent job with that.
The display is great.
It is an immersive
four-sided, non wedge display
with 90% screen to body ratio.
This means that this cream
takes almost all of the body,
giving you maximum screen estate
for the size of the laptop.
The models have up to 16 gigabyte of Ram
and up to 17 hours of battery life.
And indeed, I had a great
experience when working
with the laptop for an
extended amount of time.
So if you would like to
learn more about this,
click the link in the video description
to check out the ASUS VivoBook S14 (S435),
powered by Intel Evo.
We will see more about this laptop because
I will create the full video
of what we're going to see now
exactly on this machine.
So you will have the opportunity
to now see for yourself
what this machine can do
when we are working with it in Excel.
Before I start teaching
you all the shortcuts,
there is one thing that
is important to me to say,
and this is by no means I would claim
that I'm the biggest
Excel expert out there.
Though that being said, I did
spend several hundred hours,
probably several thousand hours even
during my professional in Excel.
And as an additional service to you,
you can download the sheet
that we will be working on
in the video description.
There's a link there.
So feel free to download it,
and then you can, in parallel,
work on it while you watch
the video and see me doing it.
So now I have the laptop
here in front of me.
I connected a keyboard and a mouse,
but the machine that this is running on
is the ASUS VivoBook S14 (S435),
powered by the Intel Evo platform.
So let me show you the
power of all of this.
And the focus of today will
indeed be the shortcuts.
The keyboard shortcuts that you can use
just to work on a bit more
smooth way in Microsoft Excel.
So let's keep us going.
And maybe you recognize this file
because this was the
same file we worked on
about two or three weeks ago
when I showed you the video
about Excel formatting.
So if you have not seen that,
I will link it somewhere
above here, check it out.
The focus of that video was to really,
to make this sheet look nice.
So we'll not go over all the key steps,
but I do want us to do a
couple of basic things.
And this is really just basic
formatting because you'll see
that there are all kinds of font types
and font sizes used here.
So let's start by
highlighting the whole sheet,
and you do that by control +
A to highlight just the table.
But then if you press A once again,
it highlights the full sheet.
Now what I do is, I usually
keep to do this manually.
So just type in here Arial
and also type in here
the font size 10.
And let's move to moving in the sheet,
because what I think is extremely crucial
is how you navigate around.
And of course, with the arrow
keys you can navigate here
in the five of this, always
takes quite a lot of time
that's not really effective.
And one very key movement
that you will literally use
all the time is pressing the control key
and then moving the arrow key.
So now I move control + arrow
down, control + arrow right,
Control + arrow up, control + arrow left.
So if you do this,
you can very quickly move
over the whole table.
This is just the shortcut
that you will use
in combination with all
other kinds of things,
just to navigate your way around the table
in a quick and direct way.
Next is about highlighting cells.
And many beginners, what they will do,
is likely they will just take the mouse,
highlight it, press down and
then move down like this.
And if the table isn't too long
with 170 lines or rows or
so, this will even work.
But if you have a table
with several thousand rows,
this can take you minutes
until you have scrolled down
in this manner.
So this is not what you do,
and instead you use your
keyboard once again.
And specifically you press shift + control
and then arrow down.
If you start here, shift
+ control + arrow down
to really highlight the
full area of the table.
Of course, then you can expand that
if you then press the right arrow button,
while you still have shift
and control knocked down,
then you can have it all marked,
or now I press up and it has
only the first one marked.
Now that being said,
let's imagine you would
want to format here
this purchasing price area
with a proper number format
using for instance, also currency icon.
So here again, we would do exactly this.
So shift + control + down to mark this,
and now we want to open
the format cells menu.
And how this works is
you press control + 1
to open this format sales menu.
So here let's imagine this
is Great British Pounds.
Then you would insert
here counting, press okay,
and now you have it all highlighted
in this accounting format.
We can do the same thing
for the quantity as well.
Let's highlight this press control + 1,
press now the number format
with this separate icon.
And now it's all in such a format as well.
Another shortcut that you
will super frequently use
is to highlight whole rows or columns.
And again, the beginner
might do that with the mouse.
You might click here on
different rows or columns
to highlight them, but of
course the overall goal
of a skilled practitioner in Excel
is to use the mouse as rarely as possible.
So we want to do that
with our keyboard as well.
And indeed, if you want
to highlight a row,
what you need to do first is to navigate
with the cursor icon to the
role that you want to highlight
and then you just press shift + space
to highlight the row.
And indeed, if you want
to highlight a column,
you press control + space
to highlight the column.
So it's shift + space for the rows
and control + space for the columns.
And another way that
you can use that really
if you present the model,
if you have this model,
for instance, projected
with a beamer to a wall,
and you're showing something,
sometimes it can be difficult
to really follow your cursor
because it's not that like
visible, not that bold,
not that in your face.
But if you want to talk
about a specific number
you want to highlight that.
A little thing that you can do
is to just highlight the whole row.
And then here, you always see
the field already highlighted
that you have the cursor in.
This really helps and the
person who was watching this,
who's sitting there with you in the room,
just to see where exactly
you are in the table.
Very much related to this
is now to insert new rows or new columns.
And here what you do is you
first highlight for instance,
the row, and then you
press control and plus
to insert a new row in
this case above that.
So we're gonna highlight it first.
So highlight the row
and then control + plus
to have a new row inserted above that.
And of cause, very similarly
it then works with the columns.
So first highlight the
column and then again,
you press the same thing.
So control + plus to
then insert a new column.
So depending on what
was highlighted first,
whether it was a row or
a column, control + plus
will insert then accordingly
a row or a column.
This works the other way around as well.
So if you want to delete a row or column,
you need to highlight
the row or the column
that you want to have deleted,
and then you need to press control+ minus.
So in this case to delete,
really the columns,
or your press control + minus
to then delete the rows.
Now, besides creating this
extra tutorial for you,
I worked with the ASUS
VivoBook S14 (S435),
powered by Intel Evo for several days now.
And I can confirm that it
is remarkably responsive
in everyday programs
like Microsoft Office.
It is also highly portable as
it is only 1.3 kilograms light
and 15.9 millimeters thin.
So if you would like to
learn more about the device,
check out the link in
the video description.
So let's work with that additional data
and insert a new column here.
Let's call that the average price,
because as you can see here,
these are different articles.
You'll see the total purchase price.
And here you see the quantities.
So many of them were purchased,
and now to have the price per unit,
what we want to do is
now just to calculate.
So here we would like to
divide the purchase price
by the quantity, then
you just press enter.
then what you do now, because
you want to have this formula
included in every single row here.
How would you do that?
And of course, now you could copy this.
And then what some people might do,
what beginners might do is
just to try to highlight this
in a way like this, just with the mouse
and then insert it here.
But of course, here, once again,
the problem is that this would
take you lots amount of time,
especially if you're working
with a very long Excel model
with thousands of rows.
Though here the problem is also that
you cannot just use the technique
that I showed you earlier
with navigating around with control
and then the arrow buttons
because if you copy this and
then press control + down,
you will end here at the
very bottom of the sheet.
So you see that this is the
row 1,048,000 something, right?
So this is not possible.
And instead, the little
hack that you can do
is that you move with the
arrows, one to the left,
you move here to the last filled column,
and then you move down
with control + arrow down,
and then you're at the bottom of the table
and then you move with the
arrow signs once to the right.
And now you can use the shortcut
that I showed you earlier,
namely control + shift + arrow up
to then have it all highlighted
up until this point,
up until where we started
here in the row three,
as you can see.
And if I now press control +
V, you have it all populated
up until the end of the table.
And maybe this looked a bit complicated,
but it's actually pretty
easy and straight forward.
Let's just go back and let me show you
how you would do this quickly, right?
So this was a starting point.
We go up and we have it all populated.
So it's like something that
will really go into your blood.
It's very straightforward, very easy.
So we just talked about copy paste.
The one thing that we would need
very very frequently is pasting values
because what you see here
is that what was copied
is not really a value,
not really a number, but always a formula.
And here another little
shortcut that you can use is f2.
So if you press f2 on such a formula,
it highlights all the cells
that are involved in a formula, right?
So we see that here, the one cell
was divided by the other cell,
and this is just what we copied over.
By the way if you press escape,
then you can always leave
this mode here again.
But here, the problem is, or
maybe it's not the problem
often this is exactly desired.
But here indeed, we
copied over the formula,
but not the values.
And of course, what
this means is that here,
if this field changes, of course
this value changes as well.
But sometimes we don't want that.
Sometimes we don't wanna copy formulas,
but we want to copy specific values,
specific numbers that
then don't change anymore.
And here the manual
mouse way to doing that
is to then highlight this,
do them with control + C,
copy this and then here with paste,
there is this drop down menu.
And then here you could
go on paste values.
And then if you would click on that,
you would see that now
these formulas were replaced
by the specific numbers
that you worked with.
So let me teach you how you
would do this with shortcuts.
And indeed first you need to
highlight this and copy it.
And then once it is copied,
you can press control + Alt
+ V and then this pastes
special menu pops up.
And here, there are lots
of things you can do,
but specifically what we wanna
do now is pasting values.
And you see that if I
now press V once again,
here now, the radio
buttons jump to values.
And then if I press enter,
then I have it all replaced
with the values indeed.
So once more, a bit
more quickly highlight,
control + C + V + V, and it is replaced.
This is how you paste values.
Pasting values is for sure something
that you will also use super frequently.
So definitely worth the
time of learning this.
So let me show you one more
thing that is very important
when you work with fixed
references and for that,
let's include here new column.
And let's imagine that we would want
to show the purchase price.
So what we see here though now in GBP,
so Great British Pound thousand.
So we want to have that in thousand.
Let's just imagine as a little helper,
we here include the number
1000 just to have this here.
Then now, what you would
of course need to do
is to divide this number by 1000.
And here too, now that will
now make it a little bit easier
for us, we just highlight this field here.
Now, of course, the problem
is, if you just copy this over,
it doesn't work.
Why doesn't it work?
Well, here and I'm pressing
f2 now, once again,
you see this, if you copy this down,
this range here moves again,
which is why you now need
to fix the reference here
of this G1 cell.
And if you want to learn
more about references,
about relative and fixed references,
once you've made a complete
video, just covering that,
I will link it somewhere
above here as well.
But here, the other thing that
you can use is to press f4.
And you see now I pressed it once.
And now we have absolute fixed references
for both the column and the row.
And now with f4, you can just toggle
through the individual modes.
Of course, what we want
to do here is to fix it.
And because then if we use
this and if we copy it,
then over just showing the
level that we did even before,
you see that this is now already copied.
Now I forgot to highlight these stats.
So now let me show you
an additional thing.
And this is very helpful
if you work with very complex formulas,
where sometimes it's
difficult to just really keep
the overview of what actually is going on.
And for demonstration purposes,
let me show you just a very
random nonsensical formula.
So completely nonsensical,
just to show us now,
a bit more complex calculation.
Now, of course, if maybe you have an error
or maybe something looks weird.
Maybe you want to know then
what exactly is going on.
If you look at expressions like this,
then what you can do is you
can evaluate the formula,
by just looking what the reside
of individual parts of the formula is.
And by doing that, you highlight the part
that you want to know.
And then if you press the f9 button,
it shows you what the number,
what the output is that this
specific element is returning.
Now, if I press control + Z for returning,
it again shows the formula,
and I can do this with
other elements as well.
I can for instance, do
this with this D5 field.
So here we know that D5 is
this 1,005,725, if I press f9,
this is exactly the number it gives me.
I can indeed also evaluate
more complex expressions.
So if I want to, for instance,
know what all this is,
I press f9 and then it
shows me the other number.
So once again, this is extremely helpful
if you want to debunk
a more complex formula,
especially maybe if a
formula is returning an error
and you want to know what
specific parts of the formula
are producing this error,
this is something that
you can frequently use.
I hope these tips resonated with you.
And let me know in the comments,
what the favorite tip for you was,
what the thing is that
you would most likely use
in your daily workforce as well.
So if you would like to
learn more about this,
click the link in the video description
to check out the ASUS VivoBook S14 (S435)
powered by Intel Evo.
And once again, if you have anything
to share, any tips that
you would like to share
to the Firm Learning community,
please leave a comment in
the comment section as well.
If you would like to play
around with the sheet
that I just worked with,
I will provide it as a download for you.
There's a download link to this sheet
in the video description.
As always, if you took any
value out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the
channel to stay up to date
on all my content.
And then I also wanna say big thank you
to all the members of Firm Learning.
You're really making a big
contribution to this channel.
Thank you so much.
This was Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
So stay tuned until next week.
Looking forward.
Until then, good weekend
to all of you, and bye bye.